Bonjour à tous
Le mal existe-t-il ?
Le mal existe-t-il ? Bon, c'est une question
qui ne date pas d'hier
on sait que Socrate disait
le mal n'est rien
bon Socrate c'était le roi de l'ironie
évidemment quand il disait que le mal n'était rien il fallait
comprendre autre chose, il fallait essayer de décaler son esprit pour essayer de comprendre ce qu'il voulait dire
mais d'une certaine manière il y a du sens dans cette phrase le mal n'est rien
et
c'est sur cette question que
j'aimerais réfléchir à voix haute aujourd'hui
notamment à travers un philosophe
malheureusement assez peu connu du grand public
qui est LEIBNIZ
LEIBNIZ est connu pour son ouvrage essai de théodicée, la théodicée
c'est l'analyse et l'étude
des propriétés de dieu
et notamment de la question
de l'existence du mal sur terre
Autorisé par dieu
Dans la perspective de LEIBNIZ dieu existe c'est un fait pour lui et donc il faut prendre en compte ce présupposé
évidemment dans une société laïcisé
c'est un présupposé qui est un peu coûteux mais on va faire l'effort de jouer le jeu
de partir du principe que dieu existe
Si on admet que dieu existe alors forcément à un moment donné se pose la question
Alors pourquoi le mal existe-t-il?
alors qu'est ce qu'on appelle le mal?
bien le mal ce sont les guerres qui tuent des civils innocents
Le mal ce sont les maladies, les virus qui tuent également des innocents
le mal c'est l'injustice, c'est tout ce qui fait souffrir des personnes qui n'ont pas mérité cette souffrance
c'est ça le mal
Et le fait est que le mal existe
le fait que des gens souffrent
sans avoir était coupable de méfaits
Le mal touche des innocents et c'est d'ailleurs ça la définition du mal, c'est qu'il s'en prend aux faibles et aux innocents
Mais LEIBNIZ
ne nie pas que le mal existe à proprement parlé mais simplement
il essaye de le comprendre et de l'expliquer
la théodicée de Leibniz va consister
à comprendre comment le mal peut exister
dans un monde créé par dieu
Dieu étant défini comme un être parfait
un être omnipotent
et un être bienveillant
comment peut-il autoriser, comment peut-il seulement accepter?
que le mal puisse exister
c'est cette contradiction entre on les propriétés que l'on prêtent à dieu
et l'existence du mal qui fait que Leibniz va s'interroger sur cette question qui est une grande question de la théologie
comment le mal peut-il exister dans un monde créé par dieu?
C'est d'ailleurs une des objections qu'on fait souvent aux croyants
notamment aux croyants religieux en leur disant mais si votre dieu est si parfait
qu'il peut tout, qu'il connaît tout et qu'il est bon
pourquoi laisse-t-il les personnes se faire massacrer?
Pourquoi laisse-t-il des maladies tuer des innocents, des catastrophes naturelles?
pourquoi? et la question est légitime
Seulement LEIBNIZ relève que lorsqu'on pose cette question
on n'est pas attentif à quelque chose de très important
Qui est ce qu'on pourrait appeler
la relativité du mal
qu'est ce que c'est que la relativité du mal?
bien Leibniz l'expliquent assez simplement
il nous dit que
le problème de l'être humain
c'est qu'il est un
un hypersensible du mal
un hypersensible
de la souffrance
on remarque ce qui ne va pas, on remarque la souffrance, on remarque les injustices
mais on ne remarque pas toutes les fois où le mal n'est pas là
on ne remarque pas toutes les fois où tout va bien
Vous savez lorsqu'on est malade, qu'on chope une bonne grippe, ou une bonne gastro
Tout à coup
on envie
le moment où on n'était pas malade, on a l'impression que ce moment où on était en pleine santé, ce moment où
ne souffrait pas
était un moment merveilleux
et c'est seulement quand on souffre, c'est seulement quand on est malade, ou quand on est malheureux
qu'on prend conscience
du bonheur qu'on ressent
quand on n'est pas malade ou quand il n'y a pas de problème
On est attentif à ce qui ne va pas mais d'un point de vue rationnel
Ce n'est pas logique
On devrait finalement d'un point de vue rationnel
mettre dans la balance
tous les moments où ça va
et tous les moments où ça ne va pas
et alors on s'apercevrait de quelque chose d'absolument
déterminant
c'est que les moments où ça va sont bien plus nombreux que les moments où ça ne va pas
J'avais fait une vidéo où je parlais du fait que la réflexion à outrance, la cogitation
excessive et pathologique pouvait nous amener à créer des problèmes à partir de rien
nous sommes très capables nous autres êtres humains
de créer du malheur à partir de rien
Et écartelé que je cite dans ma vidéo
il a cette phrase
à la fois extrêmement simple et pleine de bon sens
qui est de dire
Si vous vous posez la question de qu'est ce qui ne va pas là maintenant?
Vous allez être bien embarrassé parce qu'en réalité là maintenant il n'y a pas de problème
il n'y a pas de problème là maintenant
le problème est toujours une anticipation d'un mal futur
et lorsque le problème se présente à nous, lorsqu'il devient notre présent
on n'a plus le temps de le mentaliser, on n'a plus le temps de le penser comme problème
on doit le gérer
Si vous vous baladez dans la forêt et que tout à coup vous voyez un sanglier qui surgit sur vous
est-ce que vous pensez que vous aurez le temps de vous dire tiens là il y a un problème?
C'est votre corps qui va comprendre qu'il ya un problème c'est votre corps qui
qui va éventuellement fuir
c'est votre corps qui va réagir
Si bien que votre esprit à ce moment là est en veille, il n'a plus rien à dire
Or le problème est une notion mentale, c'est une projection de l'esprit qui correspond à l'anticipation d'un mal futur
Donc le mal est d'abord un produit du mental
c'est d'abord une projection de l'esprit et c'est quelque chose qu'on vit totalement différemment
selon qu'on le projette, selon qu'on l'envisage
et selon qu'on le vit
ce n'est pas pareil
d'anticiper un problème et de le vivre
La relativité du mal
c'est le fait que la plupart de nos maux
sont liés au fait que nous ne sommes pas attentifs au bien
nous ne sommes pas attentifs
à tout ce qui va, à tout ce qui fonctionne et à tout ce qui nous rend heureux
vous savez beaucoup de personnes qui
ont souffert d'une maladie et en ont guéri
ou des personnes qui ont traversé des épreuves très difficiles, des souffrances
et qui finalement ont réussi à s'en sortir
bien ces personnes là ont une autre approche de la vie, une autre manière d'appréhender le bonheur
Pour ces personnes-là un rien peut suffire à les rendre heureux
Comme si
l'expérience du mal
avait produit sur eux
une sorte de réveil de la sensibilité au bien
et au bonheur
Comme si finalement il fallait traverser des épreuves et souffrir
pour se rendre compte que tout compte fait
la vie
c'est plutôt pas mal
Les injustices existent et c'est un fait que Leibniz ne nie pas, d'ailleurs à ce propos
petite parenthèse
Leibniz
c'est Pangloss chez voltaire
dans son conte philosophique Candide pour ceux qui l'ont lu
Pangloss c'est le philosophe de l'optimisme, c'est celui qui trouve toujours le moyen de dire que finalement tout va bien
finalement tout n'est pas si mal et nous vivons après tout dans le meilleur des mondes possibles
Voltaire a voulu caricaturer la pensée de Leibniz qui disait
que tout bien considéré
le mal n'est pas si grave
Voltaire avait écrit un poème sur le désastre de Lisbonne que je vous invite à lire
où il ironisait
sur la pensée de Leibniz
en insistant bien sur le fait que
parfois la mort et la souffrance touchent des innocents et qu'on ne peut pas fermer les yeux sur ces injustices
Sauf que Leibniz ne ferme pas les yeux
Leibniz ouvre les yeux justement
et nous invite à ouvrir les yeux
sur le bien
J'ai intitulé cette vidéo le mal n'existe pas, c'était évidemment une provocation
C'était une manière de caricaturer Leibniz comme le fait voltaire
Car Leibniz ne pense pas que le mal n'existe pas
mais il pense que le mal est une condition pour accéder au bien
Je parlais tout à l'heure de la relativité du mal
la relativité du mal c'est de dire que
nous ne percevons le mal que parce que nous avons connaissance du bien
et c'est parce que
nous avons éprouvé le mal
que nous pouvons percevoir le bien
mais il ya une autre manière d'entendre l'expression de relativité du mal
L'autre manière c'est de dire
que le mal est toujours en quelques manières
une étape vers le bien
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire là encore?
est ce qu'on n'est pas encore dans
le discours habituel qu'on entend parfois
Chez ces
Spiritualistes ou chez ces mystiques béas pour qui il faut tout accepter?
Au nom de l'amour universel et du lâcher prise
et se dire que après tout
tout a un sens
donc le mal a un sens
Oui, en quelque sorte oui
En quelque sorte
Mais la question est de savoir est-ce que c'est faux?
Est ce qu'il est faux de dire que le mal est souvent
un mal pour un bien ?
est ce qu'il faut de dire que le mal est parfois nécessaire?
Pour accéder à une forme de bien
Et là on se trouve bien embêté parce que généralement, bien c'est le cas
Ce sont nos échecs, ce sont nos souffrances, ce sont nos malheurs qui nous permettent de comprendre
les causes et les origines de cette souffrance ou de ce malheur
Le mal nous donne toujours une leçon
et cette leçon dès lors qu'on est conscient et qu'on la met en pratique
nous permet ensuite de ne pas retomber dans l'erreur donc dans la souffrance et dans le malheur
Nietzsche disait que ce qui ne nous tue pas nous rend plus fort
C'est une manière imagée assez simple et en même temps assez parlante de traduire ce que disait Leibniz à propos du mal
Lorsque nous sommes atteints par un virus pour prendre un exemple au hasard
Nous fabriquons des anticorps
et ces anticorps nous permettront de lutter contre le virus si jamais il venait à se représenter à nous
C'est un mal pour un bien
Vous savez que quand on se fracture un os
il se reconsolide de telle manière qui devient beaucoup plus solide qu'avant
c'est un mal pour un bien
Dans beaucoup de situations de notre vie
nous agissons et ne nous trompons
nous faisons erreurs et nous échouerons
mais pour peu qu'on se montre attentif à nos erreurs
bien il est fort possible que notre erreur se transforme en leçon qui nous permettra ensuite de ne pas reproduire l'erreur
c'est un mal pour un bien
Un mal pour un bien ce n'est pas qu'une expression
Un mal pour un bien
c'est le constat
que
le mal a toujours une double face
La face subjective et immédiate qui est la souffrance
Et puis la phase objective
et qui ne déploie ses effets que dans le temps qui est l'apprentissage
Le mal nous apprend des choses
Combien parmi nous
se sont laissés
abuser
manipuler
ou blesser
par d'autres
et en auront tiré les enseignements de nature à les immuniser contre de nouvelles attaques
Il ne s'agit pas de dire que cette souffrance est une bonne chose en tant que souffrance
il s'agit de dire que cette souffrance est une bonne chose
comme moyen
en vue d'une autre fin
en vue d'une fin qui est l'évolution personnelle
C'est ça la fonction du mal pour Leibniz
Nous aider à progresser
Tout ce que nous faisons mal nous enseigne à faire le bien
L'erreur est une nécessité pédagogique
L'erreur c'est ce que l'on corrige
et on ne peut pas corriger notre comportement si on ne fait pas d'erreur
alors certains diront mais
on peut très bien faire le bien
sans être passé par le mal, on peut très bien
avoir un sens
inné
pour le bien et la vertu
oui
Sauf que celui qui est passé par le mal ou celui qui est passé par l'erreur, une fois qu'il en sort
il a conscience de ce qu'est le mal, il a conscience de ce qu'est l'erreur
Et donc il a beaucoup moins de chance de reproduire cette erreur
que celui qui n'est tout simplement pas passé par l'erreur
D'ailleurs il faut faire la distinction entre l'erreur et la faute
L'erreur c'est ce que nous commettons tous lorsque nous nous trompons de bonne foi
la faute c'est lorsque nous reproduisons cette erreur en ayant conscience que c'est une erreur
l'erreur est humaine
Persévérer dans l'erreur est diabolique
la faute c'est la persévérance dans l'erreur
On peut persévérer dans l'erreur et tomber dans la faute
on peut donc reproduire nos erreurs et reproduire le mal
Mais à ce moment là ce n'est pas le mal en lui-même qui est en cause, c'est notre incapacité
à avoir conscience de ce mal, c'est notre incapacité à le reconnaître comme mal
et dans ce cas là nous sommes les responsables
Il n'y a pas à invoquer dieu pour justifier ou pour comprendre nos propres manquements
Il n'y a pas à faire porter le chapeau à dieu de nos erreurs
Parce que si dieu nous a créé
faillible
si dieu nous a créé imparfait
et ça ne veut pas dire que nous ne soyons pas capables de nous réformer
d'évoluer et de progresser
Si dieu a créé le mal c'est pour nous pousser au bien
C'est pour nous pousser à surpasser le mal qui est en nous
ce qui suppose d'en avoir conscience
Le mal serait donc l'outil
qui permet à l'homme
parce qu'il a une conscience
de se transformer
Et de tendre vers le bien jusqu'à l'atteindre
Le mal n'est rien
non pas parce que le mal n'existe pas
mais parce que le mal n'est que le produit
de l'oeuvre humaine
ce sont les hommes qui crée le mal et les hommes pourraient décider, ils pourraient décréter de ne pas faire le mal
Si les hommes font le mal c'est qu'ils n'ont pas encore tiré toutes les leçons du mal
Je vais prendre un exemple
J'ai fait de la boxe
Et quand on fait de la boxe
on prend des pains dans la gueule
donc on a mal
et c'est jamais très agréable de prendre des pains dans la tronche
même quand on a une mentalité de bagarreur
seulement voilà
quand on prend des coups dans la figure
il arrive un moment où
on a plus envie d'en prendre
donc à ce qu'on fait?
bien on apprend à esquiver
on apprend à contrer
on apprend
à anticiper
on apprend à minimiser le mal
On apprend à éviter le mal
Et quand on fait de la boxe généralement
bien n'a pas envie de se battre dans la vie de tous les jours, alors on sait qu'on peut
On sait qu'on peut faire face à une agression, c'est vrai
mais on n'aime pas se battre au sens où on a conscience que prendre des coups dans la gueule ça fait mal
et on n'a pas envie de le faire subir à un autre même s'il a bien mérité parfois
L'expérience du mal ne donne pas envie de refaire l'expérience du mal
Et c'est ça le message philosophique de Leibniz c'est de dire que
L'expérience du mal conduit à la connaissance du mal
et la connaissance du mal ne nous donne pas envie
de rester en présence du mal
Alors certes parfois l'enseignement est long et laborieux, il faut du temps avant de comprendre
qu'on a fait le mal et qu'on ne souhaite plus le faire
Généralement ce qui se produit c'est que
ont su soi même les conséquences du mal
dont on est l'auteur
on finit par se dire que
c'est une mauvaise idée
et qu'on ferait mieux de faire autre chose que le mal
Et dès lors qu'on est conscient, dès lors qu'on est attentif aux conséquences de nos actions
bien généralement on cherche à éviter le mal, on cherche
à ne pas le reproduire
tout simplement parce que
l'homme de manière naturelle a tendance à fuir le mal c'est à dire à fuir ce qui le fait souffrir
Alors c'est vrai que parfois on s'autorise à faire souffrir les autres
et c'est seulement quand on souffre soi même qu'on se pose la question du mal
c'est vrai
mais il est tout aussi vrai que
faire le mal autour de soi
c'est le meilleur moyen tôt ou tard
de diriger ce mal contre nous
Comme disait Spinoza tout n'est que cause et effet
et très généralement lorsque l'on s'amuse à faire le mal autour de soi
et bien on crée les conditions pour que ce mal nous reviennent en pleine tête
ça n'a rien de mystique, c'est une pure loi mécanique et physique, action, réaction
faîtes du mal à quelqu'un et comptez car bientôt ce sera votre tour
La relativité du mal c'est l'idée que le mal est toujours interdépendants du bien
Ce sont les deux faces de la même pièce
Comme le jour a besoin de la nuit, comme la pesanteur a besoin de la légèreté
et si nous
faisions un petit effort
pour constater ce qui va bien
nous serions un peu moins sensible donc un peu moins soumis au mal
La conclusion de cette vidéo
C'est que si le mal existe
C'est d'abord parce que nous le laissons exister
Peut-être aussi parce que nous n'avons pas la bonne stratégie face à lui
Et qu'on ne vainc pas le mal en le combattant c'est à dire en fixant notre attention sur lui
mais en vainc le mal en faisant le bien
on vainc le mal en nous concentrant sur le bien
Merci à vous